j'invite donc bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
voilà ce set ce cri d'alarmé lancé par
le conseil scientifique il ya
véritablement une menace d'une
résurgence de l'épidémie au mois
d'octobre
pourquoi précisément à cette date juste
après l'été
d'abord parce qu'on va partir en
vacances et que au delà l'ouverture des
frontières on va rencontrer un seul
angle gens et que c'est le contact avec
les gens et avec les gens qu'on ne
connaît pas ce qu'on peut appeler le
deuxième une troisième sia qui est à
risque de finalement on perde la trace
de ce virus lors des enquêtes de contact
racing est encore une fois l'objectif
c'est de casser la chaîne de
transmission
et puis il faut se rappeler que cette
date elle prend aussi en considération
la fin de l'été on sait qu'avec l'été
les ultraviolets notamment sont quelque
peu vire ici c'est à dire que ça peut
tuer en partie du virus et qu' il y aura
moins de virus ça c'est une certitude
cet été et donc on à risque d'avoir un
peu plus de virus circulant à l'automne
circulent d'autres virus respiratoires
comme le rhume saisonnier et d'autres
courants d'un virus d'ailleurs ce qui va
rendre compliqué l'équation
il ya aussi à l'apparition de nouveaux
foyers en france
plus de soixante dix c'est ce qu on a
révélé est ce que justement ces foyers
aussi sont à risque d'une propagation
alors ces foyers il faut finalement sont
félicités parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle il ya plus de 151 de mémoire
cluster identifiés en france
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
était capable d'empêcher le virus de se
propager à plus grande ampleur notamment
au niveau des départements et des
régions est de faire en sorte d'avoir
les conditions d'une deuxième vague au
sens de la première c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on parle de deux mba et il faut
comprendre qu'on parle des malades à
l'hôpital
aujourd'hui les malades à l'hôpital sont
extrêmement rares ya très peu de
nouvelles entrées à l'hôpital parce que
justement on arrive à empêcher ces
malades de faire défense
vers puisqu'on diagnostic chez des gens
souvent jeunes et ce qu'on appelle peau
si certains ont peu ou pas de symptômes
et qu'on isole immédiatement et
l'objectif comme l'a rappelé le
président de ms c'est de détecter
massivement pour pouvoir bloquer les
chaînes de transmission en mise au lent
les cas qui sont contaminés donc
aujourd'hui le dépistage systématique
c'est ce qui peut limiter en fait la
propagation du coronavirus absolument
maladies infectieuses n'y a pas qu'à
rentrer outils il ya le dépistage
d'isolement et où le traitement
aujourd'hui pour le courant navires us
malheureusement il ya pas traitement
validé à part des données sont le tulle
intéressante pour des maladies graves à
l'hôpital ce qui est pas la question
aujourd'hui des corticostéroïdes est
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut faire
c'est des pistes et massivement isolé et
puis bien sûr les règles d'hygiène on a
vu ces dernières semaines c'est à dire
le lavage des mains la distanciation
sociale et surtout le port du masque qui
est extrêmement utile et puissants face
au virus à transmission aspire à 3
justement comment est ce que vous avez
réagi en voyant les images de la fête de
la musique on a vu qu'il y avait
énormément de monde à paris
les gestes barrières n'étaient pas
observé pas de port du masque est ce que
voilà ce sont des mesures essentielles à
conserver a gardé jusqu'à au moins
l'auteur de voir après c'est exactement
ce que j'allais répondre c'est qu'il
faut garder ces mesures au moins jusqu'à
l'hiver jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pourquoi parce que déjà il ya une menace
de deuxième vague et que l'on sait que
c'est maintenant que ça se joue plus
vite on aura pris ces mesures plus vite
on contiendra le virus et plus vite
l'épidémie s'étende à si on fait des
demi-mesures en maladies infectieuses
dans santé publique on sait que c'est
inefficace parce que la transmission du
virus le fameux vers zéro qui est le
risque de reproduction continue à
grimper et donc on perd du temps face à
la maladie et aujourd'hui il est
extrêmement important de comprendre que
c'est parce qu'on a mis le masque parce
qu on a confiné et parce qu'on à
respecter l'ordre républicain finalement
que ces mesures de santé publique se
sont avérées efficaces
et on voit bien que les manifestations
alors on en état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 10 juillet encore ne sont pas
d'actualité parce qu'elles ne sont pas
nécessaires à la nation malheureusement
c'est un fait et parfois en temps de
crise il faut savoir respecter les
règles et probablement qu'il faut que
ces règles soient plus claires à l'année
dernière
question quand est-ce qu'on pourra dire
qu'on a complètement éradiquer ce virus
il faut un vaccin on sait que la course
a été lancé ce que vous avez voilà
quelques informations à ce sujet vous
avez raison de souligner la ce qui
permettra probablement de façon certaine
de sortir de cette crise et d'avoir
humilité de population c'est à dire
d'avoir au moins 60 à 70% des gens au
sein d'une même population qui est
assurément immunisés et le vaccin nous
permettrait d'avoir vraiment des
chiffres de cette ampleur est donc une
sortie de crise de façon certaine
aujourd'hui on sait que si un vaccin ça
sera probalement pas avant mars 2021
donc il faut rester patient et pendant
cette patience s'armer de logique et de
rigueur sur le plan de l'hygiène
notamment pour tenir bon et ne pas se
retrouver confronter deux silva merci
beaucoup
benjamin david et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches